another movie that's based on a true
story but it's a true story of sports
meets math and that's awesome Moneyball
so Moneyball is the story of the manager
of the Oakland A's played by Brad Pitt
and they're kind of the lower tier
baseball team sorry - Oakland fans yeah
it's true for the movie so all the other
huge baseball teams on huge budgets are
just drafting up everybody and they get
the leftovers and a first movie was kind
of slow you know you're like okay we get
it Brad Pitt's down on his luck the
team's not doing so well but a half an
hour into the movie he meets up with
Jonah Hill and then you get the point
Jonah Hill plays a Stanford graduate who
has a degree in Business Economics or
something like that and he has come up
with a way to pick players and drafts
based on the statistical probability of
wins like in the sport of baseball you
won't get drafted based on you know just
certain thing it's like Oh 40 years old
you won't get Drive did you have a weird
looking pitch as a guy he was like he
throws like a 90 mile an hour fastball
but he throws it all weird and underhand
looks for the math involved it's all
about putting together a team that
ensures that players get on bases you
get players on bases you get players
home you get points you win it makes
sense like that and that's the system
they've come up with they have a budget
of like 30 million dollars it's not much
in the world of baseball but a lot of
the players that hold the best
mathematical probability of helping
their team win they can buy for like two
hundred thousand bucks it's kind of like
miracle you know he's not looking for
the best players just the right ones at
a point I thought to myself it's kind of
like counting cards in the casino then
Brad Pitt says in the movies like we are
counting cards the blackjack table boys
we're gonna turn the odds in our favor
which is so awesome like I'm not a big
math guy I hated math in high school is
just like X plus y equals Z I'm like all
right yeah that sounds great thanks I
don't know how I'm gonna use this in my
life and I haven't ever but what I can
see the practical application of math
that's when it's awesome and of course
like everyone else in the sport doesn't
like it at all like all the sports
advisors have like 28 years baseball
experience on them they're all just like
you can't bring math into baseball's all
about real men real sports real trucks
real beef yeah they're not happy about
it but Brad Pitt and Jonah Hill it like
no you play the odds in your favor you
stick to the numbers you stick to the
probabilities you will win
mathematically speaking it makes sense
and Brad Pitt's really good in the movie
you can tell when this guy puts his mind
to it he's a good actor and Jonah Hill
is really good in the movie too he
really shows us why he's actually the
good actor that passed on transformers 2
so he's good and smart and I like Jonah
Hill and Brad Pitt working together
there are a good team they're good
actors it worked this is one of the
biggest surprises of the year for me I
didn't know what to expect from the
movie I was like to be good could not
it's a genuinely good movie it's an
underdog story it's a true story I like
stuff like this it's inspiring it has
good acting in it the movie seems a bit
long movies lately have been like an
hour and a half hour 45 minutes this is
about two hours ten minutes long so you
feel it doesn't change the fact that I
thought it was worth it it is a little
slow at first so it takes a bit to get
going but in the end I would say it's
worth buying on blu-ray so your favorite
baseball movie you don't have a favorite
baseball movie what's your favorite
sports movie comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more real beef
[Music]